[Music]
with tensions Rising around the globe
the president will make a direct plea to
the American people saying there's an
urgent need to keep money flowing to
Israel and Ukraine he can't seize his
neighbor's territory and get away with
it as simple as that and they're going
to stay the course we going to continue
to provide military equipment so that
Ukraine can defend itself and its
territory and its freedom including
additional resources that the Congress
is going to give me today of 13 billion
more dollars since the War Began the US
has committed more than $3 billion in
assistance to Ukraine well President
Biden is sending Congress an urgent
request from military aid to support
Ukraine and Israel in their respective
War efforts now according to multiple
reports the request is expected to be
for just around hundred billion 60
billion going to Ukraine about 10
billion for Israel and the rest going to
Taiwan and to support the US mexic meic
border America stands behind Israel
period I also asked her whether America
could afford to support two Foreign Wars
at the same time and a similarly clear
answer to that
[Music]
absolutely so you're a politician and
you have a problem you only make
$174,000 a year you're basically in
poverty I mean come on your salary is
even less than what the average doctor
makes in the US and they're not saving
the country like you are as the savior
of the nation you need to be paid
handsomely but how are you going to do
that well even though you may not have a
big salary what you do have is Insider
knowledge and influence now all you have
to do is learn how to monetize that
influence because listen there is no
guarantee you're going to be in office
forever so you've got to make the most
of your time in power you got to milk it
for all its worth like these public
servants if these guys can go into
office broke and come out multi
multi-millionaires why can't you and one
of the best tools at your disposal that
you can profit from is foreign aid
ah yes Americans are suffering but
everyone around the world deserves a
little democracy wouldn't you agree we
all know that most foreign aid is BS but
how and how can you benefit from it well
to find out I decided to ask an Insider
this is Sean Spicer and he's as much of
a Washington Insider as you can get he
served as the White House Press
Secretary and communications director
under Trump so he has seen it all and
now he's dedicated his life to exposing
how the system actually Works he
recently launched the Sean Spicer show
on YouTube we'll link it below so sit
back relax and let's learn how to skim
off of foreign
[Music]
aid if you're like the US government and
you ship stuff to other countries or
domestically then you got to check out
ship station did you know that over 50%
of negative reviews come from Shipping
problems like shipping delays yes that
is right 50% so if you have a business
that ships stuff one of the best things
you can do to grow your business make
more money while reducing your stress is
by using today's sponsor ship station
ship station helps you automate most of
your manual shipping work while also
hooking you up with the best shipping
rates out there with up to 89% off from
Top carriers like UPS USPS and DHL
Express Joe Rogen's onor brand used ship
station along with 130,000 other
companies and if you want to give it a
try you can get started with a free
trial in less than 5 minutes with the
link below all you got to do is create
an account then you connect your
Merchant accounts like Shopify eBay ety
or Amazon most marketplaces and stores
are supp Ed and finally you connect your
shipping carrier account or you choose a
new carrier and that is it now you can
ship stuff way quicker with less
headache this includes instant tracking
updates a tool for Carrier price
comparison and much much more so get
ahead of the Holiday Rush while saving
money on shipping by going to ship
station.com jren today to get a free
60-day trial that's shipstation.com jren
for a free 60-day trial with the link
below let's say you're a politician and
you're running for office for the first
time well step number one is you're
going to need a lot of money if you
can't raise money it doesn't matter it
it you can argue all day long whether
that's a good thing or a bad thing or
how corrupting it is it's a it's a truth
campaigns cost money they cost a lot of
money you need to pay for a staff you
need to pay for get out the vote efforts
you need to pay for political mail
polling uh tv ads Internet ads a website
emails all of those things cost money
and they're costing more and more for
context if you want to become a senator
you're going to need to spend an average
of $15 million and where are you going
to get that 15 mil well you definitely
don't have that kind of money yourself
you're probably still paying off your
student loans so you're going to have to
raise it but who are you going to raise
this money from who is going to have
millions of dollars lying around just to
throw out some new politician well it's
going to be large corporations like
Black Rock LOE Martin Ron and so on so
what happens is number one you have to
raise a lot of money to get elected and
you go to donors and political action
committees that are companies and ask
them to support you when you are running
okay great so let's say you were able to
raise a ton of money and you got elected
great right now you can finally start
making a difference wrong now is not the
time to celebrate and actually do
anything because now you have to
immediately start worrying about getting
reelected and guess what getting
reelected is going to cost even more
money and who are you going to get this
money from large corporations like Black
Rock lucky Mar Ron and so on now if you
get elected then you become even more
dependent on them why because it's not
just your own reelection but as you want
to climb the ranks in Washington DC well
hey I want to get on this committee I
want to become a chairman on this
committee well you know the more you
help your other colleagues and help the
team out that's going to be seen as a
positive for you so what do you do you
want to raise more money you want to
give more money to the party to the
leadership to your fellow colleagues all
of that stuff and so what does that mean
that two three nights a week when you're
in Washington DC you're raising money
you're hosting fundraisers you're
attending fundraisers for somebody else
uh it is a unbelievable critical
component of being in office and getting
in office because guess what if you want
to raise more money from the same people
you're going to have to start returning
some favors you're going to have to show
them some results taking money from
donors is kind of like if you were to
run a startup and take money from
investors now you got to answer to your
investors you got to answer to your
figurative board of directors if you're
in office unless you plan on retiring
getting reelected is probably your top
priority how do you get reelected one
you make make sure that you keep the
folks that elected you to know what
you're doing that they're happy they
think that you're accomplishing stuff
now hopefully in many cases those issues
align that something that you supported
people who who agree with your position
are backing you so it's not as
corruptible as like I'm going to flip my
position because you gave me money
usually people who agree with you on a
particular position want you to stay in
power so that they'll support you so if
you believe let's say that you are a uh
a big Hunter and a big supporter of the
Second Amendment well then you're going
to go to the NRA US Concealed Carry
Association and people who support
Second Amendment rights and say hey
would you be willing to continue to
donate with me could you have a
fundraiser for me could you send out a
solicitation for me but it's it's it is
a constant battle once you get an office
to raise enough money to stay in office
and so you are constantly thinking of
the people that supported you and
there's no question about it and what is
the one thing that all the biggest
corporations and defense contractors
that donate to politicians all want they
all want more foreign aid
[Music]
right now you've got a lot of arms
ammunition military equipment that's
being spent and Biden's own State
Department put out a report talking
about the massive corruption that's in
there so you say to yourself well then
why and I think part of this comes back
to there are people that benefit from
this there are people that make a ton of
money so I've always said Jake that two
things are always at the root of
everything power and money and when you
look at what's going on in a lot of
foreign policy somebody's benefiting and
what's happening in Ukraine is 90% or
plus of the aid is in the form of
Munitions we're sending them a weapon
system a plane a gun ammunition well
who's making that the defense industrial
complex somebody back here a defense
contractor A munition supplier is making
it America has sent more than $75
billion in Aid to Ukraine since the War
Began more than 60% of that has been in
the form of weapons or money
specifically earm marked for buying
weapons and military supplies and who's
manufacturing all these weapons ammo and
equipment for Ukraine why is the
American military industrial complex of
course lock Martin R the on Boeing and
so on the same thing with Israel to some
degree we're supplying things for their
Iron Dome we want them to have the
Weaponry in Ukraine we're sending a lot
of stuff over there and then by the way
dirty secret we've got to resupply it
here so if we send them 10 guns right
somebody built and spun those but then
we've got to fill the coffers with 10
more guns somebody's making money off of
that and that's where you know the dirty
little secret is somebody is benefiting
the more foreign aid America sens to
Ukraine and Israel the more money
American defense contractors stand to
make so if you're looking to get
campaign donations from a powerful donor
like Ron or Boeing well they are only
going to support your cost if you
support their cost I mean these folks
the military-industrial complex spends a
lot of money making sure that members of
Congress that are for them stay in
office so there's two things one is
direct contributions the other thing is
they employ a lot of people and they can
inform those people who's been friendly
to them so if you're job if you have a
job at Boeing or locked Martin or
wherever and you're being told hey
Congressman X or Senator y has been
particularly helpful to us they're good
for us they're good for your job well
guess what that ensures that they get
they get to stay in office so they do
everything from direct contributions to
making sure that the employees their
families their communities everybody
knows who's been helpful to them as a
company your job your future your
lifestyle relies on their success in the
2022 election cycle locked Martin
donated nearly $4 million to the
campaigns of dozens of Congress members
if they're voting your way if they're
supporting the policies if they're
advancing the legislation or they're
getting the Appropriations for the
things that your company your industry
cares about you're going to want to see
them stay in office what does that mean
it means that you're going to host a
fundraiser form you're going to attend a
fundraiser form you're going to do what
you can to make sure your employees know
that they'll even shamelessly donate to
your campaign at the exact same time
you're discussing possible foreign a
bills but it's not just the obvious
military contractors a profit off of
supporting War
it's also big money firms like Black
Rock Vanguard and so
on put yourself in the shoes of one of
these giant investment firms like black
rock or imagine yourself as one of these
big investors like Ken Griffin or Bill
Atman as one of these Giants you are
always looking for guaranteed wins
you're looking for big Investments where
there's zero risk which is where places
like Ukraine come in sure on the outside
Ukraine looks like the riskiest
investment ever why would you want to
invest in a country that is at war with
Russia but think about it if you know
the us is going to unconditionally
support Ukraine to the ends of the Earth
fact of the matter is that I believe
we'll have the funding necessary to
support Ukraine as long as it takes if
you know that you can influence all the
US politicians to keep supporting
Ukraine then an investment into Ukraine
is the most guaranteed investment you
could have ever asked for what
investment is better than one that is
backed by the US governments if they
know that if they invest in that the us
is going to sending money I mean think
about it it's a guaranteed win on top of
that Ukraine has been decimated they
barely have an economy which means
you'll be getting in on this investment
at the literal ground floor your
investment can't go down because there's
no more down to go it's like if you were
to buy a stock when the stock price is
at $0 why do you think in June 2023
Black Rock and JP Morgan announced the
creation of a reconstruction bank for
Ukraine their aim was to quote attract
billions of dollars in private
investment to assist rebuilding projects
in the war torn country End quotes and
all they ask for in return is to be able
to get the First divs on future
investments in Ukraine wow how nice of
them why do you think Ukraine's
president recently had a secret meeting
with people like Ken Griffin Bill Amman
Black Rock Vice chairman Philip
hillerbrand and a bunch of other Finance
Big Shots the meeting even included ex
US Secretary of State Henry Kissinger
these big money names are investing in
the seed round of Ukraine which means
they're going to need you congressmen to
support Ukraine no matter what so if you
are getting ahead of the game knowing
that you can't lose in a particular
investment because the US is sending
funds and ammunitions Etc they can start
to play both ends of the spectrum right
so they can be supporting the
politicians they can be supporting and
investing in the defense industrial
complex on one side of the ocean and
then they can be going over the other
side of the ocean and being the
beneficiaries of their somehow through
an investment they are constantly
looking for ways to maximize an
investment and I think there's no
question they're doing it here in the
United States in terms of politicians
and positions and what they invest in
and then I guess the idea is you look
overseas and figure out who's going to
benefit if you know that the US
government is going to invest $2
billion1 billion anywhere and you can go
St plant your flag and say great we'll
be the ones that invest here and build
here you get to double dip you get to
invest in the company here in the US
that's being backfilled by the United
States government and then you go to the
other side of the coin and you become
the recipient of that investment through
an investment that you make over there
there's no question about it now you may
be saying but Jake there's got to be at
least some politicians that are
supporting Ukraine in Israel because
they actually believe in it right and
yes there is some truth in that in the
case of Israel in particular it's very
personal for a lot of folks there's a
huge Jewish population in a lot of
districts but then there's also the I
mean Israel is our greatest friend in
the Middle East so there's a big
strategic value in continuing to support
Israel that I think a lot of these
members see in the case of Ukraine as I
said it's twofold one you've got people
who recognize the threat that an A
continuing encroaching Russia poses on
Europe and the freedom there and that is
a big problem because here's the thing
Ukraine is not a member of NATO why does
that matter well Article Five of NATO
says that an attack on one is an attack
on all so let's say that Russia instead
of Ukraine goes somewhere else and
attacks a NATO country by the treaty
that we have signed on to we need to go
in and support that country so if we
don't stop Russia's aggression in terms
of Ukraine when they go somewhere else
that's a a NATO member suddenly we are
obligated under Article 5 of NATO's
treaty to come in and support that
that's boots on the ground our troops
over there in Europe pushing back in
Russia so the idea first and foremost is
if we stop Russia now and then it sends
us signal don't go any further secondly
if we don't stand up for them then what
signal does that send to China what
signal does that send when they go want
to take over Taiwan for most of these
members of Congress in this particular
case I think that they are mostly drawn
because they want to support Ukraine as
a check against China or because they
don't want to see an advancing Russia
but then there's going to be some that
that are looking at it and also I mean
in the back of their mind there is an
aspect of this which is hey by the way
when we replenish all of these things
that are getting sent over to China it's
actually creating us jobs in my district
because they're buying this Weaponry Etc
so as you can see there are many motos
that play here some legit many not
legits but even if you're not able to
profit off of Israel and Ukraine
directly fear not because we still have
many more options to get
[Music]
rich the average member of Congress and
I'm not talking about president or
Senator but just your average House of
Representatives member is something like
12 times richer than the average
American household once people get
elected they almost always get richer
the average member of Congress I think I
think it was in
2014 uh became a millionaire and so I
think that the Gap has widened uh and in
the last four decades uh the average
member of Congress has something like
doubled their net worth while the rest
of us are kind of treading water or
maybe even going backwards in some cases
the next option you have to make money
is a classic influence pedaling and the
greatest Master at this were by far the
bidens the stuff that Hunter Biden has
done I think has exceeded any amount of
grifting that I've seen in the past the
idea that you're sitting on the board of
a company Bera in particular that he had
zero qualifications I mean he's not an
energy guy right he doesn't have any
foreign policy experience and they're
paying him a massive amount every month
why they admit it it was a Griff they
knew that his father had was vice
president at the time and they're
putting him on the board then he's
getting all these contracts from China
Etc yeah there's no question that is the
definition of influence pedaling that
this is what they were getting for they
they make no bones about it and then you
can also use your position of how to get
better loans or access to Capital that
the plus would never be able to get take
Joe Biden right he's been in in in
government for 50 years and suddenly
he's got a couple million dollar Beach
House well how does that happen you know
I wrote a book called radical Nation
where I talk about his brothers and you
know they're getting loans that none of
us would ever qualify for um and so you
can get they use their access uh not
just them but sometimes family members
to get access to Capital uh and funding
that that the normal person wouldn't
access to Capital and Loans are are
these Banks do or these lenders doing
that because they know they might get
some ancillary benefit from giving them
the money 100% of course they are right
they know who who who regulates them
they know who passes legislation and
laws that affect them so there's no
question about it and I mean this this
has been going on for you know and and
once in a while Congress will try to
strengthen its ethics rules and police
itself you you read story after Story of
politicians who got sweetheart deals
sweetheart loans and it's not just the
the number there are times when you
would wonder how could someone qualify
maybe for a loan of x amount that they
wouldn't normally based on their salary
or their assets and well gee just so
happens around the Banking Committee and
of course there's the stock trading and
and then you've got a lot of members of
Congress in the last couple years you've
got busted trading stocks so you know
it's not insider trading per se but
there is a an aspect of it where if you
know legislation is going to affect a
particular industry or there's going to
be a regulatory action and you could go
out and buy that stock because you know
that a committee is going to investigate
something there's going to be fines um
you can bet on things that you know are
going to go up and you've seen Congress
try to police itself there's an act
called the stock act but for a lot of
these guys they're able to make
investments and do things and if not
them then maybe their wife maybe their
kid goes out and makes an investment or
does something that benefits uh the
family and obviously if you think about
it you you they that person have access
to information that none of us do they
know what the government's going to do
that might adversely help or adversely
hurt or help a company or an industry
because of an action that the
government's going to take so if you
know that well then you go out and you
make the right bets and boom suddenly
you know your $10,000 becomes $50,000
the 50 becomes a 100 and the 100 becomes
a million and you go from you know
someone coming into Congress that didn't
have that much to walking out doing
pretty well with so many ways to make
money if you play your cards right you
too can walk out of Public Service as a
multi multi-millionaire and being that
Congress are the ones that write the
laws there is no chance in hell they're
ever going to try to fix any of this so
really the only way to stop any of this
the only way to stop all this grift
corruption all the stock trading is to
Simply have term limits for congress
people after all we have term limits for
the president why don't we have term
limits for everyone else if you could
only be in Congress for maybe 5 or 10
years instead of decades like today's
career politicians it would be
impossible for them to accumulate all
this corrupt wealth but is there even a
slight chance we would ever get term
limits do you think there's ever a
chance of getting term limits for
congress people you know I don't Sean
goes over his take on term limits in a
new debate on his channel that you can
watch right now by clicking the card on
the screen in this debate they talk
about whether or not it's even ethical
to limit who people can vote for and
whether or not Congress would ever
actually police themselves like this
it's a great discussion if you thought
Shawn was insightful in this video then
you are going to love his channel so
click the card on the screen to watch
now and don't forget to subscribe to his
channel as well stay dangerous and we'll
see you in the next
[Music]
one